but
um back to mo theory which is where
what we talked about uh last friday and
and there are sort of two last things i
wanted to to mention now
uh related to ml theory before moving on
to the topic of hybridization
now before i do that you know i'm going
to use a couple of videos today and i'm
not going to
show you this one but i just want to
mention there's lots of videos that help
you know animate this stuff right so
like this is what you know
so like oh okay
bonding molecular orbitals
anti-bonding we talked about this last
friday but look at this animation
i couldn't do that on the board watch
this
kind of remembering stuff now right from
friday
oh look at that
that's that kind of animation that you
just can't you know i can't animate the
bonnie and anti-bonding well i kind of
can with my hands but
but there it is and there's lots and
lots of those kinds of videos i'll show
you a couple today related to
hybridization because it really does
help
see these 3d orbitals right in their
full shape and what's happening so i
highly recommend
if especially if you're having like some
conceptual uh
questions related to stuff we talked
about friday and today
take a look at some of those videos now
where we left off
uh on friday before i get to nitro
nitric oxide which has all those
different uses in the world
um and many more we left off with the
the the homonuclear dimers that's what
we were doing on friday
right how do the atomic orbitals come
together to make orbitals that are
molecular
mo's right um and and we did it for
for dimers that have the same atom right
and so here so we did nitrogen and two
and we did o2
right and so let's do that on the board
and that because now
we're going to start with one that has n
and o
heteronuclear dimer right two different
atoms
but if i had the same one remember this
is what it would look like right so here
here would be say n2 would
you know i'm going to just stick with
the valence so the the 2s
for a nitrogen atom and the 2p
would have remember hund's rule
right okay so that's what the 2p would
look like and then over here
we would have the other atom this is how
we
roll when we talk about mo's and we'd
have the 2s over here
and this is how we start these are my
aos for the two nitrogen atoms right
this is what we did we're just getting
back in the mood
because we had the long weekend and when
we make the mos remember we have all
those sort of things that we talked
about in terms of
how these this
difference between the bonding and the
anti-bonding orbital
right is related to the the overlap and
the same symmetry
of the two aoes that come together as we
talked about that the more
overlapped the biggest this delta goes
in tight right
and then we also so that would be filled
this would be filled
right sigma 2
s sigma ah sigma
star 2s right uh and then for nitrogen
we also talked about how oh boy
these are reversed right so you i'm i'm
now already
backwards twice which is not what i want
okay
and this was but this is the weird thing
about nitrogen because
if we go to oxygen then the way it goes
is
you know you've got your 2s and oxygen
okay
and in oxygen you've got your
your 6 valence electrons in the 2p
and over here you've also got
the same okay and you've also got the 2s
and but for oxygen
okay so those are the sigma sigma star
but for oxygen
we go to the ordering
that we usually have
which is that remember those pi orbitals
have and this isn't necessarily drawn to
scale but
those pi orbitals right so this is sigma
sigma star
and these are the pi orbitals pi and pi
star right
sigma p sigma p
right 2p 2s
sigma this would be sigma s sigma 2
sigma 2 star
sigma 2 p if you want to be exact about
it sigma 2 p
star pi x pi y
pi x star pi y square we talked about
all this on friday i'm just
getting us back in the mood but the but
the way we left off was that
these are okay so for if i fill these
all up now
right remember we do the mo filling then
we'd have this
and this and
now hold on yep this and
there and there for oxygen
and then over here we're filling them up
we got those are filled those are filled
and this is filled for nitrogen
remember i showed the movie pouring
liquid oxygen pouring liquid nitrogen
oxygen has unpaired electrons
which means it's paramagnetic it has
unpaired electrons the o2
dimer this is o2 these are the mos of o2
these are the atoms
these are the mo's of n2 n2 doesn't have
any unpaired electrons so it's not
paramagnetic
but the thing that we left off on that's
what i'm saying is that these two
switch order
for those dimers for lithium through
nitrogen
those two switch over we talked about
that on friday the reason is
because for those atoms these
uh sigma now these sigma
uh uh p orbitals can
mix in with the sigma s orbitals
and so you get more because remember the
more overlap
the greater the energy right the greater
that delta between bonding and
antibonding right
so the more mixing you have the more
spread you get
and it's so much that for those dimers
you you push the orbital
up okay that's all what we talked about
friday
now i got one of each and i wanted these
on the board
so that you can see them
as we now take one atom from one side
and one from the other
it's actually kind of what you expect
you just have to have one thing in mind
when you think about no so if this is
n okay over here
and we're gonna put uh 2s
there and 2p there here
here here here there's my n atom
and now i've got o over here so i've got
my
but now see the thing is o is more
electronegative and the way this works
for a heteronuclear dimer
is let's write this on the board so for
a hetero
nuclear that means that the two atoms
are different
okay but for a heteronuclear dimer
the bonding mo's
are closer
in energy to
the more electronegative atom
electro neg
atom
adam so what that means is that if i
draw
so if i draw my oxygen levels but you
know this right
you know this also from all the the work
we did on atoms
right you know a little something about
remember this axis is energy
this axis is energy right and so if this
is 2s for oxygen
and then the two p's are going to be
sort of like here
okay
and we'll fill them up thinking about
hund's rule well now
what we're going to have is that those
the mo's for the no
molecule are going to come
closer they're going to come further
down
from that side right then they come from
that side you see that there's an
asymmetry
i made it kind of subtle i made it and
why is this curved
that's not good what's going on here
there's a little bit of an asymmetry
here
right so
so this is lower down these are lower
down
right so when you draw your orbitals
now oh man
i'm going to draw this a little bit
lower
right so now when you draw them
you see that bonding orbital is going to
be closer
you see this is a bonding orbital still
it's still bonding
right it's a it's going to be a sigma p
sigma 2p
but it's closer in energy to the more
electronegative levels you see that
right so it's not symmetric anymore
okay and then the same would happen with
these guys
right they'd be closer in energy
to the yeah they would be closer
and i'm not leaving myself enough room
here that's why i've got some videos
they do it better right
okay we'll leave that one there it's a
little bit better
not much but a little bit
so the b now oh by the way it for no
let's talk about mo for a second because
there's another thing
that's important that we talked about
which is bond order
and you know so the bond oh
electron configuration is another thing
right so like the the configuration
we can write this out right
so the configuration of say o2 would be
sigma 2s right you're just filling them
up with two electrons
sigma star 2s with two electrons
sigma 2p with two electrons
pi two p with
four electrons and then pi
two p star with two electrons that's how
that
looks it's a little bit messy but i hope
you can read it
that's just reading up right it's the
electron configuration of the mos
just like we would write the spd
electron configuration of atoms but this
is a molecule
now sometimes you might you know
something would say there's a convention
we use which is that the pz is the sigma
ah nobody can agree on so different
textbooks say pxp
but we're saying if pz is sigma then
this would be like a sigma 2 pz
right and and you might if you really
want to write this
you know you might write that that's pi
2 p x if you really want to keep track
of it
there's two orbitals in there you didn't
fill one orbital with four electrons
right
so this would be pi 2px
and pi 2py for right that's what's
happening in there
okay now but the other thing you can see
from the bond from this
this filling is also the bond order
right and so for the bond order
bond order
here you would have a half times and
it's all of the
remember the bonders all the bonding
electrons minus antibonding electrons
divided by two
right and if it's zero it's not a stable
molecule if it's greater than zero
stable and the higher the bond order
the higher the bond strength right so
that's also from friday
and so this is two minus two
plus four minus two and so you get
two nope i missed it two
plus two plus four minus two
2 minus 2 that kind of cancels out right
plus 2 plus 4 minus 2
all divided by 2. so the bond order for
oxygen now the bond order for no
bond order for no
is going to be uh 2.5
well it's kind of interesting now you
can see okay so no is stronger
more strongly bound than o2 less
strongly bound than into and it's kind
of interesting
how can i make no a stronger a more
strongly bound molecule
well i can take an electron away it's a
little bit counterintuitive
right because for no plus
the bond order goes up because
the electron that i've taken away was in
an anti-bonding orbital
right so no plus actually has a stronger
bond than no even though it has one less
electron you get this all from just
looking at which electrons are occupying
which orbitals
ah in this case you had
in this very much not drawn to scale
oh boy figure right
what you had was one up there
so if i take that out my bond order
increases
right okay all right
and the last point i wanted to make
about mo theory before we talk about
hybridization
is with one other example and that's hcl
okay so for hcl you got something else
happening
that's important so we just talked about
electronegativity
driving where the you know that this is
tilted
okay fine and now we got the fact that
chlorine
comes into this situation you know it's
like
chlorine is like hey i got seven
electrons
right and hydrogen is like hey i got one
so how does this work right so this gets
to what
was brought up friday which is there's
another
type of mo and it's not bonding and it's
not anti-bonding it's
non-bonding that is not the same as
anti-bonding non-bonding doesn't take
sides it just is because the way this
works is you know hydrogen comes at this
okay so hydrogen's up here with this 1s
chlorine is you know let's say over here
it's got 3s
filled and it's got let's draw these
you know here okay 3
p and chlorine's got 7 electrons in the
3p
do they do they all come together and
form mo's no
they can't because there's only one on
this side
right so this one orbital will
form let me ah let me
make myself enough space so i'm going to
exaggerate this a little bit
so this one orbital
will form a sigma bond
sigma 3p sigma
3p bond this would be a sigma 3p star
now that's exactly what we've already
done
right the the sigma but
but oh there's something a little
interesting about this one right
because it's an s it's an s
but that's okay because the s can talk
to a sigma
p this we talked about the s can talk to
this
that's okay because it's aligned
right now but these guys don't have
anyone to talk to they don't so they
can't make their pie
orbitals they can't do that and so
they just stay there these stay there
exactly at the same place
they're not doing anything different
they're just hanging out those electrons
are nonbonding so these are not these
are not pi
orbitals sigma and pi
are special names they refer to these
orbitals that
of them of the molecule that involve the
lcao
the linear combination of the atomic
orbitals
these do not n
b and b
that's what we'll call them just to be
very clear
just to be very clear now they're filled
they're filled
and they do not count in the bond order
by the way
this is also a non-bonding
orbital that's a non-bonding orbital
non-bonding orbitals these are not going
to count so in the bond order
you only have you have one half
times two minus zero equals one
these do not participate in bonding i
got to fill this
two electrons are in that one okay
so that's another example of something
that happens in
these mo diagrams one of them brought
too many electrons to the party
and so there's no one to to to talk to
but it's okay they're just gonna stay
there and wait
maybe something else will come along
right okay
now that is right there what i just drew
look at that 2p 2s and you get this
thing
right oh that's a beautiful molecular
orbital between
okay fine it was a 1s and a 3p but
you get the point it was a p oriented
along the axis
with sigma symmetry that means if i look
along the axis sorry
cylindrical symmetry sigma means if i
look around the axis
everything's the same in a circle right
right
so but and so that's a nice sigma
orbital
between two different atoms mo theory
but see the other thing that can happen
that is something that i want you to
know today
is that orbitals on the exact same atom
can
also do this they can also do this
they can combine to form a new orbital
sp same atom forms an sp orbital let's
call the hybrid orbital
right so we're going to give a couple of
examples this is hybridization
high britization
and let me give a couple examples in my
why this matters
so this is when two or more
aos that are similar
in energy they're similar they're not
the same but they're close you can you
can't hybridize if one level is way up
here and the other levels way down there
but if they're close to s2p
then those orbitals can combine
and what they do is they combine to form
and this is critical
sets of
equivalent
orbitals
properly oriented this is really
important that's why i'm writing it all
out properly not proper t
properly oriented
to form bonds oh this is such a big
a big deal to form bonds
it's the last word there but i did it
all caps to emphasize
because that's what this is all about
you see because it now let's take an
example
i'm going to take an example of methane
who brings what to the party okay i got
h
i got four h's h 1s
h 1s h
1s okay this is definitely getting
repetitive
h 1s but i did it
there they are and they come and they're
like hey carbon what you got
and the carbon is like okay hold up i
got my 2s
that's here and i got my all my
two peas and what are we to do
what are we to do how can these four
hydrogens come and bond with the carbon
given that it looks at least like the
carbon
isn't bringing the kind you know how is
it going to do this
and also and this is critical this is
why i wrote it here
properly oriented to form bonds you see
because
this taps into what we learned with
vesper
it does because vesper says you gotta
not
repel oh no you're repelling but try to
minimize it
that's what's at the core of vesper so
what this system sees is a way out and
by way out
i mean a way to happiness and by a
weight of happiness i mean a way to
lower energy
where all four of these can bond to the
carbon atom if it has
four same bonds if it had four
same bonds then it can orient them
tetrahedrally
and make vesper happy minimize
repulsions
right and you get your methane molecule
so what ends up happening is this carbon
atom
says hold up you four hydrogens you wait
there
i'm just gonna go into the back and do a
little reorganization
and i'm gonna come in it with i'm gonna
say well if i had
if my carbon atom comes at
comes at it with four equal orbitals
that look like this
those are called sp3 because i took
all three p orbitals and i mixed them up
with my s
orbital and i formed equivalent
orbitals now carbon comes out of the
back room and it's like
hydrogens i'm ready i can make a a
minimum energy
vest and i can follow vesper and we can
have all have very very low energy
compared to whatever else i could have
done if i stuck like that
what i'm really talking about okay you
might know
carbon you know it doesn't go into the
back room it doesn't but what is it
doing
it's nothing more than solving its
rotinor equation that's what this is all
about
you just change the boundary conditions
you
and so what happened that's all
hybridization is
you're solving the schrodinger equation
all the time we are always solving the
schrodinger equation
all the time and in this case carbon
said well how can i solve it and
minimize my energy with the four
hydrogens
this gives you the lowest energy because
now
oh i got a movie now i can make those
see so i have a i have a picture here s
and those three and it says how can i do
it and minimize repulsions this is how
three equivalent four equivalent
orbitals to make it sp3 and this is
where i think a movie helps i'm gonna
play this it's like a minute long
each 2s orbital is a two-lobed shape
converging at the nucleus
there's a 2s so there are the three 2p
orbitals
however when hybridization occurs the
snp
orbitals cease to exist they don't cease
to exist that doesn't
they just didn't ex it's a new boundary
condition you're solving the equation
right so just to keep that straight
right and the
two sp3 orbitals have an entirely
different shape that's true
we can see that orbital hybridization
explains the vsepr placement of carbon's
four valence electrons
since all four two sp3 orbitals are
equivalent
each two 2sp3 orbital repels the others
with equal force
resulting in identical bond angles
the carbon atom only hybridizes when it
is in a bonding situation
here 4 hydrogen atoms bond to carbon by
overlapping their orbitals with
carbon's hybrid orbitals so what would
be the reason for this
if we go back and see that both carbon
and hydrogen have
unpaired electrons the overlap allows
the electrons to pair and thus go to a
lower potential energy
oh that's such a beautiful place to stop
lower potential energy
happier that's what this is all about
okay so i i you know like i said you can
see now the difference right if you just
wat is one minute long
and i think it really brings it to life
so if you if you're again want to see
this
a little bit more conceptually these
movies are good and one more uh movie
i'll show you
like a minute long um okay now the thing
is
so what we just did is we did carbon
hybridizes to sp3 it's called sp3
because you're bringing three p orbitals
and mixing them with s
to form four and that allowed it to do
this but you see if i had ethane which
is c2h6
it's the same thing now because
basically what's happening
a carbon atom comes into the system of
ethane and it says
i need four bonds that are kind of you
know
ish all right i gotta give one to each
hydrogen and then
you gotta give one of that other carbon
over there
and by doing that it can minimize its
energy it can minimize repulsions it can
be the happiest molecule it can be
but to do that carbon must have these
four
equivalent sigma-like bonds it must be
able to form those four equivalence
suits so that's very similar to
methane except that in this so also
ethane
will be sp3 hybridized it will have sp3
hybridized orbitals
but then and you know it's coming right
so ethane
has c2h6 but what if now
i've got ethylene i think i have maybe i
have a picture of it
do i have a picture of it yeah oh there
it is ethylene
ethylene is used this this tiny molecule
is two carbons and
four hydrogens instead of six this is
used in so many applications i can't
possibly list them
is polyethylene is a polymer made out of
this as a base
we will polymerize this a little bit
later in the semester when we talk about
polymers
it's also used in the back of your
supermarket in case you know that
very soon actually kind of almost now
ish most of the fruit we get will be
super green when it gets here and then
they use ethylene
to actually induce uh sadly
the ripeness doesn't taste as good
but anyway okay now but for ethylene
you've got a different situation because
for ethylene each carbon atom
needs three bonds each
carbon atom
needs three equivalent bonds
and it can do that too
so so for c2h4
each carbon atom needs three equivalent
bonds and it can do that if it
hybridizes in the sp2 hybridization so
let's draw that right so these are
the original orbitals of carbon
and they will go to
three sp2 orbitals
notice i can put one electron in each
ready for action
ready for bonding one electron in each
of these equivalent
hybrid orbitals sp2 and i've got one
left over
ho ho oh one left over
but you see the one left over is a p
orbital
that didn't get in on the hybridization
but that's okay that's okay
these are p right so this is s and this
is p
2s 2 2 p and there's a p orbital right
there those are my hybrids and that's a
2p orbital
this is there's another 2p orbital on
the other carbon
also got left out now i only needed
three because
you see i formed this nice spatially
maximized to minimize repulsion right
separation maximize to minimize
repulsion so it's a planar
oh but it's planar for another reason
because
each of these carbon atoms has a p
orbital and we know
that 2p orbitals can form a pi bond
right and i have a picture of that
that's exactly what they do
so so this is the sigma
the hybrid orbitals are sigma right
because they're along the axis and look
at them
if i look down this axis i can draw a
circle
and there's full cylindrical symmetry
right
but i've got this left over p orbital
here
on each carbon atom that's that one
there
and and i didn't need it to do this but
it's still there and so it forms a bond
it forms a bond right it forms a pi bond
so that p with the p from the other one
forms a pi
and a pi star right in the mo's and you
you occupy the pi with the two electrons
and that's a bond
so so in this you've got uh you've got a
bond from this
uh that's above or below and you know in
this orientation it's above or below the
plane and you've got a bond from this
so you've got a double bond that's
exactly what we know already
but we know so much more now we know so
much more
because because now we know that it's
not just two
you know two bonds and four electrons we
know that they have shape to them we
know that they have structure to them
and we know that those bonds are
different
these are pi bonds and that's a sigma
bond
right and you also know why this
molecule stays planar
because if i try to twist it then those
p
orbitals won't align right it's like a
little spring if i
if i try to twist it it's going to go
right back because its minimum in energy
is when these things
can maximize their overlap right so
that's going to stay planar
okay now and so so for this case
you've got a double bond
so this is a
double bond and i think i have a little
carbon carbon double bond
and i think i've got a video to show
this because i i this is another
case where you know again i just want to
make sure you guys get the intuition
here and i thought this is a pretty cool
animation of sp2
so i'll play it for a minute
2s and 2 of the 2p orbitals hybridize
consequently
this hybridization is termed as sp2
hybridization
the hybridization leads to the formation
of three equienergic
sp2 hybrid orbitals
as you can see each sp2 hybrid orbital
is bi-lobed one loop bigger than the
other
the half-filled p orbital which was not
involved in hybridization
lies at right angles to the plane of the
equilateral triangle
now let us understand how this
hybridized state
results in the formation of a double
bond
for this imagine a similar sp2
hybridized carbon atom
approaching this carbon atom as these
atoms come closer
an orbital overlap takes place along the
internuclear axis
this bond is called a sigma bond
at this stage the unhybridized p
orbitals which lie
above and below the plane of the sigma
bond
also come very close to each other and
overlap laterally
resulting in the formation of a pi bond
between the two carbon atoms
all right okay so the
i thought about it i watched that movie
of course many times over the weekend
and i thought about can i animate you
know the electrons like that and do the
and i i think i could but i don't know
that it would be a good use of our time
so i thought that they did a pretty good
job of bringing it to life
now this is a great time for me uh
to tell you about my why this matters
and of course
the sp2 carbon atom matters because of
drinking water of course
um and you know this is a well in in a
district in india where more than 50
percent
of the wells exceed the who limits for
arsenic
by around a factor of five
1.8 billion people in the world drink
fecally contaminated water on a daily
basis
600 million people boil their water in
the world
um boiling doesn't help with arsenic
though arsenic just stays
in in the boiled water it kills bacteria
but it doesn't help with toxic
uh toxic elements um
if you look at the world as a whole and
you look at sort of where there are
water
water crisis where the water crisis is
at this level
it's it's a little over three and a half
billion people
and in those countries almost 185 or so
countries
um where this is a serious problem if
you look at the cause
of disease and the cause of death
in those countries 70 to 80 percent of
all disease and almost 30
of all death can be attributed to the
water quality
right so uh when i talk about water as a
problem i
really mean it's a serious problem it's
a problem of life or death
um now this is to get
fresh drinking water if you look at the
planet and you say well where is the
water on this planet
where is the water on this planet i like
this
picture because
we consume water volumetrically not in
an
area right we use water as a volume
and this is the water we have on this
precious planet as a volume
this bubble here is all of the ocean
water
it's about 70 it's about 97 of all the
water
that bubble there is fresh water that is
inaccessible
right it's frozen and this one here you
can't really see it there is another dot
there
that's less than one percent of the
world's water that is our drinking water
ecosystem
that is what we are destroying um
and but see so what okay so there's a
lot of things we can try to do about
this
right one of the things we can try to do
is to see if we can tap into this
in a way that's more affordable and more
efficient
because there's a lot of water here
right and use that
but the problem is if you look at the
cost of desalination
today as opposed to the cost that's
desalination if you look at the cost
as opposed to just digging water out of
a well like the one i just showed you in
india
it's over a factor of 10. still and
and in fact one of the the big issues
with desalination
isn't just the the total cost or the
operating costs but the capital costs
how do you build this plant in the first
place
right um and so it takes too
much money
if you look at the the thing that's at
the heart of desalination
it's a filter right it's a filter and i
talked about this in my last why this
matters
when i talk about separations and i
promise that in my next why this matter
i talk about water
right which is what i'm doing um if you
look at a desal plant this is one of the
world's largest this is a plant called
the hedera plant in israel
and you look at what their costs are
that remember the causation half of that
cost
almost half of the cost isn't just
energy and almost all of that energy
is in pushing salt water through a
filter
through a membrane that's called the
reverse osmosis membrane because you're
going against the osmotic pressure
um and if you look at the membrane
itself
this is a picture of it it's actually
very small layer on top of this active
layer
um that does all the work it's not a
very
good design in fact membranes for
desalination
are pretty bad right
they kind of do everything worse than
they should except that they work
which is good and they're cheap dollar a
square foot but
but see they're very they take much more
energy than you need
they foul up very easily and then that
means stuff gets
kind of you know stuck in them and then
you can't take it out you can't clean
them because these
these polyamide membranes which is the
same polymer used in these membranes for
50 years
haven't changed the material
those polymer membranes are destroyed by
chlorine so even
in a desal plant in a d cell plant if
you have drinking water in your feed
drinking water has six parts per million
chlorine that's not much
they still will go through the cost to
remove it
they will remove it from the feed why
because if you leave that little amount
of chlorine in the feed
these membranes get destroyed by the way
there's 40 000 of these membranes
in this plant each one is two meters
long and 40 square meters of area
so so these are so delicate
that you can't really clean them well
and that's part of what the cost of a
plant
involves right that's part of what the
cost of a plant involves now
this would be like a plant right you
have sea water coming in
and you know and then you've got your
membrane module that's taking the salt
out of the water
and then the product water but because
this this filter
is so delicate there's the picture
because that filter is so delicate you
actually have to add a whole lot more to
the plant
so much of a decel plant is built around
essentially protecting this membrane
so that's cost that's cost right
a better membrane could change this but
like i said the membrane
oh there it is you can't you can't
snapchat on that
snapchat what is it that people do today
not snapchat yeah
snapchat yeah okay thank you you can't
snapchat on that that's what i meant
i know it's not myspace but i don't know
but anyway um
uh this is like you know when i look at
at at membranes today as a material
sciences materials chemist
i look at members i think that's what it
looks like why
it doesn't have to be the case we can do
so much better
and and so okay energy and cost goes
into pre-treatment secondary treatment
and this is where this comes back this
beautiful material
that we have now understood more than we
did before because remember before
i showed you graphene and i showed you
no i showed you benzene
and we talked about it as a lewis
resonance structure remember
all right a lewis resonance structure to
help explain how it look
you know gra graphene does not have
alternating bonds remember that's what
we talked about before
it's a lewis resonance structure so it
lowers its energy
by having two sets of structures
that have sort of alternating bonds we
talked about it in the context of
benzene but see now you know so much
more
you know so much more because now you
know why graphene is so special
you know why graphene is so special it
actually is
the hybridization it's the hybridization
because on top and on the bottom of a
single atom of
of a single sheet of graphene
you've got pi bonding all the way
those pi bonds are going across the
whole surface and those
electrons are critical those electrons
that occupy those pi
orbitals are critical to the the very
special properties that graphene has
so you now know the secret it's sp2
hybridization
and you know this has allowed us this is
you might i'm kind of passionate about
this problem partly i'm passionate about
a lot of problems but also we happen to
work on this
and we have been developing this this is
like the ultimate membrane
i can soak this in chlorine overnight i
can put it in negative ph solutions i
can heat it up
it doesn't degrade and we have figured
out how to poke holes in it
at just the right size or to stitch it
together
so that maybe you can filter particles
by the flow in between these sheets
right
and this material as a membrane is so
promising
that we've actually started to
commercialize it as of the last year
right and i think this is really going
to make a big difference in a lot of
a lot of areas why because of sp2
hybridization
that is why that is why this is such a
special material
okay that's my why this matters now
oh we did c2h6 there it is we did c2h4
there it is
look at that extra pi bond not animated
this time and of course
you can go on and you could do c2h2 and
you can imagine what happens in this
case
is is what you would expect is what you
would expect
because now i've only got see each of
these carbon atoms
only needs two sigma bonds one to the
hydrogen and one to the other carbon
so it's only going to grab one it's only
going to hybridize
to make those two equivalent sigma bonds
so i'm going to hybridize with one of
the p
electrons so that's sp that's
sp hybridization but notice that in c2h2
you know now i've got um two p
orbitals left over on each carbon atom
and so you can imagine that with these
two
p orbitals well you you know this
already right when when we talked about
p
orbitals we talked about
how you know you might you know you've
got this right
ah okay that's supposed to come like out
of the plane and into the plane they're
orthogonal
they're orthogonal right and so
so two of them are coming at the other
atom
one is like this and the other's like
that and the other and then the other
atom is one like this and one
well it might not at first but then when
it sees those it's like hey wait a
second
if i do this we can pi bond
but the other ones are like this and
they pi bond and so you get a
carbon-carbon triple bond
right you get a carbon-carbon triple
bond for c2h2 with
sp hybridization now it's not oh there
it is
right okay forms pi bond network form
sigma by network
it's not just carbon that hybridizes
it's not carbon is a classic example
but you know if you look at beh2
it's the same thing beh2 well
be be starts
with an on
star can i raise this up v e starts
with orbitals that don't look like
they're going to give me the equivalent
two sigma bonds b e starts
with these s electrons filled
right but if b
had something more like this
if it had an sp electron in each of
those
orbitals well now when i see the two h
orbitals the two 1sh orbitals
coming at me i can form those equivalent
bonds so be h2 will also hybridize
to make that molecule and all sorts of
other things
the d orbitals can get in on the action
right so here's sf6 which we talked
about we drew this
lewis structure took a long time to draw
those lone pairs but now you know that
the way this actually works because
those are equivalent bonds
so the only way this can work is if i
form hybrid orbitals
right right but they didn't have to be
equivalent bonds until we learned about
vesper
and it said no i want to maximize my
separation
to minimize repulsions and so then we
know that if they're
equivalent bonds the energy of the
system will be lower
right and and so that that's uh
you know that's that's gonna have to
take some d orbitals and create
these hybrid orbitals look they're
beautiful because now this thing
from the sulfur this thing can say hey i
can take six of you and i can be
equivalent bonding to all of you
that's what hybridization is okay it's
it's written right up there we're just
keeping on saying the same thing
okay now um
i think that i'm i got very excited
about the water so i have to throw some
t-shirts out
um and and now i where do i where do i
okay i don't go there
i don't go there i gotta go
back there and back there and then oh
that's very loud
okay and right there and right there
see you guys on friday
you